[Music]
on this Monday night the Russian
president's promise for punishment
Vladimir Putin's message for the leaders
of that short-lived Russian Rebellion
but with any attempt to create internal
turmoil is doomed to failure as Wagner's
Evgeni pagosian breaks his silence
Wildfire smoke chokes Ontario and Quebec
it's definitely harder to breathe the
health concerns and when mother nature
will help clear the air
plus playing chicken wow great flavor
the texture is really nice the potential
Ripple effects of growing meat in a
petri dish
National with Donna Friesen reporting
tonight Jeff Semple good evening and
thank you for joining us the Russian
president is breaking his silence after
Saturday's short-lived Rebellion by the
mercenary Wagner group in a late night
TV address a visibly angry Vladimir
Putin says the leaders will face Justice
Russia
the insurrectionists Betrayed their
country and their own people and they
also dragged others into their criminal
schemes lying to them pushing Russian
soldiers to kill each other this is the
outcome that Russia's enemies want
Putin's speech appeared to drive a wedge
between Wagner's leaders and its
soldiers thousands of whom have played a
critical role in Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Putin says those soldiers who
took part and later stood down will not
be prosecuted and he also thanked
ordinary Russians for their Unity
well just hours earlier the leader of
the Wagner group also spoke out
insisting it was never his intention to
overthrow the Kremlin these latest
contradicting statements are raising new
questions about what happened and what's
next for Putin and his war in Ukraine
Redmond Shannon has our top story
tonight
Vladimir Putin's address to the nation
was short pre-recorded and provided
little in the way of inspiring rhetoric
but he did clarify one question
the embattled Russian president said the
leadership of Saturday's short-lived
Mutiny will be brought to Justice the
Rebellion temporarily captured the city
of rostov on Don and advanced to within
a few hours of Moscow by leadership he
meant of course Wagner mercenary group
boss yevgeny pregosian who he again
refused to mention by name
Putin also assured the ordinary Wagner
soldiers who stood down later on
Saturday that they will not face
punishment
just like Putin pregosian waited until
Monday to address the remarkable events
of Saturday a day that ended with
supportive crowds cheering him as he
left rostov on Don we
in precautions 11-minute Memo from an
unknown location he claimed the
Rebellion did not aim to depose Putin
only to hold the defense minister and
head of the Armed Forces to account
pragosian said he stopped short of
storming Moscow to prevent blood being
spilled even though this rebellion was
was quashed bloodlessly it totally
encourages anybody else who wants to
have a go to have a go at Putin and
Russia is the most Dog Eat Dog Place U.S
investor Bill Browder has campaigned for
a decade for more sanctions against the
Putin regime even more damning I would
say for Putin's reputation not to take
this pregosian you know take him to the
middle of red square or set up a
guillotine and chop his head off on on
public television
thanked Belarusian president and Ally
Alexander lukashenka for brokering
Saturday's deal an agreement which said
pregosian would move to Belarus if
progosian is there his safety is far
from assured Putin is believed to have
signed off on targeted killings in far
less friendly locations and for reasons
far less serious Redmond Shannon Global
News London
in that speech Putin also suggested the
West Was likely behind that failed
Russian Rebellion but U.S President Joe
Biden says the U.S was not involved and
he's been in contact with America's
allies to coordinate a response
that we had to make sure we gave Putin
no excuse let me emphasize the gay Putin
no excuse to blame this on the west or
to blame this on NATO
we made clear that we were not involved
we had nothing to do with it this was
part of a struggle within Russian system
the turmoil is also overshadowing a
summit of Nordic nations in Iceland
Justin Trudeau is the first prime
minister to attend the meeting meant to
boost cooperation among Arctic Partners
but the chaos in Moscow dominated to the
agenda three isri is traveling with the
prime minister in Reykjavik turia
Jeff the Nordic leaders plan to focus
mostly on increasing cooperation in the
Arctic and fighting climate change but
their agenda took a detour okay leaders
of Nordic Nations gathered for the final
day of talks but their discussions
revolved around someone who was not in
the room Russian President Vladimir
Putin Iceland invited prime minister
Justin Trudeau as a special guest this
is obviously a very
challenging internal situation in Russia
this is the head of a significant
military paramilitary organization in
the Wagner group you know taking some
bold actions challenging the regime we
discussed the events of last Saturday in
Russia which show us really how
unpredictable the situation can become
through Nordic countries that neighbor
Russia the risk is even more real we
have to be ready
and I'm happy that we are well prepared
at this moment the West is well prepared
NATO is well prepared but we have to be
ready
[Applause]
Finland recently joined NATO the
organization's Secretary General called
the short-lived rebellion in Russia
another signed Putin's war in Ukraine
was a mistake
demonstrates how how difficult and
dangerous this for uh President Putin to
be reliant on Mercenaries Sweden is
pushing to become a NATO member ahead of
next month's Summit in Lithuania and we
need to make sure that he gets you in by
uh by illness in a couple of weeks
Trudeau met with his Swedish counterpart
on the sidelines
but turkey is standing in the way the
Turkish president is blocking its entry
into the alliance accusing Sweden of
harboring terrorists the Turks and
swedes will have a sit down in Brussels
before the NATO Summit prime minister
Justin Trudeau says he will continue to
support Sweden's bid for membership as
Western leaders try to respond to an
increasingly unpredictable Russia Jeff
Iceland thanks to Ria
Toronto voters cast their ballots today
to decide the next mayor of Canada's
largest city more than a hundred
candidates were in the running for this
by-election and if opinion polls are
right Olivia Chao could Triumph tonight
the former NDP MP was the perceived
front-runner throughout the campaign but
her lead in the polls narrowed over the
final week after a surge and support for
Anna bilau bylaw received a last-minute
endorsement from John Tory who resigned
earlier this year after he admitted to
an affair with a staffer
well it was another day of smoggy skies
in parts of Quebec and Ontario drifting
smoke from fires burning in Northern
Quebec lingard keeping air quality
advisories in place for much of the day
more than 450 fires are burning across
the country and roughly a quarter of
those are in Quebec it's already the
worst Fire season on record for that
Province Mackenzie gray reports on the
impact of the smoke and how long it's
expected to last
one of Canada's most recognizable
skylines stuck in a haze as smoke from
forest fires in Northern Quebec
continues to blanket Montreal I think
this is about it half an hour outside
and we're going to go in for the second
day in a row outdoor activities closed
or canceled with the air quality Health
index listed as high risk but that
didn't stop some montrealers from
getting their exercises it's definitely
harder to breathe I must say I feel like
you gotta like pace yourself more I'm
sure about public health saying today's
poor weather won't have long-term Health
impacts I think people don't need to be
overly worried about long-term impacts
of for example a couple of days that
we've had up till now but in general we
know that reducing exposure to fine
particles at any time and for any
duration is a good idea Canadians are
used to a bit of hot air coming out of
Ottawa but today the peace Tower was
shrouded in Smoke and despite the Eerie
look it was actually an improvement from
Sunday we'll see winds from the south
and it'll push that smoke back towards
the fires towards the Northern parts of
Quebec but that reprieve might be
short-lived Environment Canada modeling
shows an even heavier band of smoke
settling in over the next 72 hours
covering parts of Ontario Quebec and
even some Northern U.S states and it's
not just Americans feeling the fires
some 4 000 kilometers away the sun went
orange on the Portuguese island of the
Azores and satellite images shows the
smoke even made it to Mainland Europe
hitting the tip of Portugal the area
burned in Canada is about the size of
the province of New Brunswick I mean my
gosh that is a huge piece of of
geography that that we're burned we
burned this year there is one positive
there's lots of rain in the forecast a
major thunderstorm actually just rolled
through here in Ottawa and it's on its
way to Montreal jeff which will help
clear some of the smoke from the air
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks Mac
wow at least one person was killed and
another injured after tornadoes tore
across Indiana on Sunday homes were
ripped apart and hundreds of thousands
lost power some areas reported hail up
to 10 centimeters in diameter well in
Texas a dangerous and deadly Heat Wave
is now entering its third week
temperatures in some places are expected
to hit nearly 50 degrees Celsius in the
coming days
the U.S Coast Guard is scouring the site
of the wreck of that Titan submersible
salvaging what it can from the ocean
floor five men were killed when that
vessel imploded on a dive to the wreck
of the Titanic there are now multiple
investigations to determine what went
wrong and as Mike Armstrong explains
multiple families are now grieving their
loss
just a week after losing five people at
Sea the polar Prince is preparing to
head out again it was the mothership
that launched the Titan submersible it
stayed on scene as part of the search
and returned to Port Saturday its next
trip is with a different organization
well new details are now emerging about
its last trip
I was on the ship in an interview with
the BBC Christine dawood confirms she
and her daughter were on the Polar
Prince when her son and husband were
lost
Darwin says she was supposed to be on
the Titan when it Dove to the wreck of
the Titanic she instead gave the spot to
her son suleima he was excited dalwood
was on a lower deck on the Polar Prince
having a snack when she was told the
ship had lost Communications with the
sub I think I didn't comprehend at that
moment what that meant
and then it just went downhill from
there
that would says during the search she
stayed hopeful but knew time was running
out it was after 96 hours when the sub
would have run out of oxygen that things
changed that's when I lost hope
and that's when
when I even then sent a message to my
family on Shore I said I'm preparing
for the worst
the funeral prayer was held at the St
John's mosque Sunday though it says they
remembered all five of The Men Who were
lost
now the Salvage operation at the site of
the wreck continues a remotely operated
vehicle has made several Dives the loss
of a submarine crew or a submersible
crew is very close to home for me Carl
Hartsfield is a former U.S subcommodore
he was embedded with the Coast Guard
last week during the search operation
Hartsfield says rovs can recover debris
of almost any size but it is complicated
he says and delicate imagine if you were
on top of the Empire State Building and
you had a tennis ball on a string and
you were trying to put it over a manhole
cover
now the world is used to seeing images
of the wreck of the Titanic not of the
Titan the U.S Coast Guard says it will
not release images or even a list of
what it finds but those items will be
important to all three investigations
now underway the U.S Coast Guard the
Transportation safety board of Canada
and the RCMP are all looking at the
Titan tragedy there's no timeline on how
long it'll take for those investigations
to be completed the TSB said this week
and it could be 18 to 24 months the U.S
Coast Guard said simply it will take as
long as it takes Jeff Mike Armstrong and
St John's thanks Mike
Making a Splash coming up one kayaker's
close encounter with a curious whale
the shooter who opened fire inside an
lgbtq2 plus nightclub in Colorado last
year was sentenced today Anderson Lee
Aldrich pleaded guilty to five counts of
murder and 46 counts of attempted murder
that's one for each person inside Club Q
as part of the plea deal the 23 year old
also pleaded no contest to two hate
crimes Aldrich received five consecutive
life sentences without the possibility
of parole a cyber security incident is
causing disruptions at some petrocan gas
stations across the country
numerous locations are now only able to
process cash transactions and petrocan's
app and loyalty program are also
unavailable parent company Suncor says
it's working with experts to investigate
and resolve the issue Suncor says at
this point they found no evidence to
suggest customer data has been
compromised
well we
was this for a close encounter Drone
footage captured a curious humpback
whale swimming alongside a kayaker at an
Australian Beach he says he was close
enough to touch the whale with his
paddle the two cruised through the
Crystal Waters together with unassuming
swimmers just nearby Witnesses say the
whale followed the kayaker about two
kilometers before they went their
separate ways
[Music]
fighting for their lives still ahead the
international outcry over uganda's
efforts to criminalize its lgbtq2 plus
community
Uganda is facing growing International
outrage and condemnation over its new
so-called
anti-homosexuality act last month the
company approved the bill which can
include life in prison or even the death
penalty for anyone engaged in homosexual
acts there are fears other African
nations could soon follow suit and as
Jamie Dahl reports from Uganda it's left
that country's lgbtq2 plus Community
afraid for their lives
the law is considered one of the
harshests in the world and those in the
community here say they've had to build
their walls even higher and are being
pushed even further underground out of
fear of severe punishment you know is it
being surveilled this is Kenya Jiro not
her real name we are protecting her
identity because she is bisexual even by
talking to us on her phone in the dark
of night she is taking a risk security
person who just showed up and they just
posed until right now
oh my God are you okay yes I am
because you know that's that's the kind
of thing that's happening right now
because you don't know you're not sure
you don't know who who is going to be
picked up or for what reason same-sex
relations in Uganda have always been a
crime with a potential life sentence the
new law calls for the death penalty for
lgbtq people having sex with a minor or
if the accused has an illness like HIV
that was found promoting homosexuality
could face 20 years in jail that's the
fear that we're living with yeah so it's
um
people are being attacked on the street
yes and they're being arrested but then
those who are not being attacked also
have this that anxiety
Frank magusha has already been arrested
in Uganda the openly gay activist is in
Canada and sat down with prime minister
Trudeau he's at the Forefront of the
fight against the law he's returning
home the other anti-gil legislations
coming up in other countries so the
spillover is real so the urgency of
responding and fighting back to stop
these anti-gil legislations is urgent
right now International organizations
like the Stephen Lewis foundation in
Canada are working to help secure safe
housing for those in the lgbtq community
in Uganda this Ugandan government
representative wants other countries to
focus on bigger problems the Western
countries are more interested in that
bill than other predictions we have very
many problems in 2014 a similar law was
overturned by the Constitutional Court
here in Uganda and similar petitions
have already been filed once again
regardless of the legislation the
Canadian government says it will be
steadfast in its support for those most
vulnerable here but it stopped short of
saying if any sanctions would be imposed
Jamie dog Global News and tebe
[Music]
a finger looking good scientific
solution next the lab-grown poultry
that's changing meat production
[Music]
please join me
in a round of applause as we wish our
crew well and they enter the habitat
four volunteers have embarked on a mock
Mission to Mars for the next 378 days
they'll be living inside a 3D printed
1700 square foot simulated Mars habitat
it includes a kitchen private crew
quarters and two bathrooms NASA says the
participants will take part in various
missions including simulated space rocks
and crop growing that mission is
designed to plan for successfully
sending people to Mars for real
and some major scientific breakthroughs
could soon be served at your dinner
table last week the U.S department of
Agriculture gave the company the green
light to sell lab-grown chicken meat
that means genuine meat made from the
ground up using cells no Farms or eggs
required Mike drolet brings us a taste
of how it works
foreign there's nothing pretty about a
chicken coop it's a mass of Beaks
feathers and chicken attitude and how it
gets from here
[Music]
to here most people would rather not
know
[Music]
just want their chicken tonight but
would they want this nugget which was
grown in a lab and even chefs have a
hard time distinguishing from the real
thing wow great flavor
pictures
[Music]
oh yeah basic food biology isn't being
written on barbecues it's in labs and it
comes with a healthy side of questions I
mean like is is it genetically not
chicken
what's the deal
the deal is yes genetically it's chicken
minus the beaks and Feathers they start
with taking cells from a living animal
then they're placed in a bath of
nutrients inside a bioreactor where they
multiply and grow and then in as little
as two weeks it comes out looking like
minced meat all that's left is to shape
it so it looks like the real thing I
like the real thing
The Real McCoy
so I wouldn't uh
wouldn't be interested in it wasn't so
long ago plant-based burgers were
raising eyebrows now they're everywhere
cultivated meat allows people to eat
meat without slaughtering animals
removing cruelty concerns meat created
in a lab still requires energy but less
so than traditional animal agriculture
methods which involve large chunks of
land and significant water use so
there's the opportunity to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions a positive for
the planet granted there's a learning
curve here
because the idea of 3D printed meat
still might be a hard sell for some
would I buy that no no well let's give
the industry time to develop into
whatever shape it wants apparently
microwave Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm Jeff Semple we'll stick
with the food and beverage theme for
tonight's your Canada Davidson
Saskatchewan lays claim to the world's
largest coffee pot you know thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you